في وقت حرج تتزامن اضرابات عماليه في كل
من بريطانيا وفرنسا على خلفيه مطالبات
تتعلق بزياده الاجور وتحسين ظروف العمل
استهدفت نقابات عماليه عطله عيد الميلاد
باضرابات متلاحقه
من ليله الاحد سيتوقف عشرات الالاف من
عمال السكك الحديديه في عموم المملكه
المتحده عن العمل ويقول المضربون ان نصف
خطوط السكك الحديديه ستغلق كما ان
القطارات في معظم اسكتلندا وويلز ستتوقف
قالت صحيفه الجارديان ان اكثر من 16 مليون
شخص يسافرون برا عشيه عيد الميلاد ونقلت
الصحيفه توقعات شركه تحليل بيانات النقل
ان تكون اوقات الرحلات البريه اطوله بنحو
14% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام الماضي
لن ينخرط عمال السكك الحديديه البريطانيون
وحدهم في الاضرابات المجادوله سلفا بل
ستنضم اليهم نقابه عمال الاتصالات التي
تشمل عمال بريد ونقابه التمريض وموظفوا
الجوازات في ثمانيه مطارات السلطات
البريطانيه استعانت بقوات من الجيش لتعويض
اضراب موظفي العديد من المرافق المحتجه
كالاسعاف والجوازات رئيس الحكومه ريشي
سوناك اعرب عن استيائه مما وصفها بالفوضى
الناجمه عن تلك الاضرابات مؤكدا فتح باب
الحوار مع منظمها في فرنسا وبحسب شركه
السكك الحديديه الوطنيه
في مسافر من اضراب ينفذه سائقون ومراقبون
وعمال في السكك الحديديه ادى الى الغاء
اربعين بالمئه من الرحلات القطارات فائقه
السرعه شكوى المطربين الفرنسيين هي هي
تحسين الاوضاع ورفع الاجور وتخوض الحكومه
معهم مفاوضات لالغاء اضرابات مرتبه لدى
عوده الفرنسيين من العطله
فرنسي حول ما يوصف بالاحتكار النقابي
لتنظيم الاضرابات على مواقع انخراط
مجموعات غير نقابيه في الدع الاحتجاج
والاضراب وهو ما قد يعني خروج الامر نسبيا
من يد الكيانات النقابيه ويلقي بالتالي
ظلالا على مصير اي مفاوضات بينها وبين
الحكومه